-Susan, welcome.
-Aw.
Everybody's live.
-Yes.
We're here. We're here.
-We're still here.
-Thank you so much
for coming to the show.
-Thanks for having me.
I missed you guys.
You grew a beard,
so that's how long it's been.
-Yeah, I've grown up.
I went through puberty
since I've seen you and I'm --
[ Laughter ]
It's a fantastic thing.
How was your summer?
-Working, working, working.
Did a bunch of movies. Yeah.
-Wait, I heard about one movie
that you're doing that's a DC.
-DC comic, "Blue Beetle."
-"Blue Beetle."
-And what's fabulous is
it's the first Latinx hero
that has his own movie.
And it's really --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's major.
-Even better --
all of the Mexican --
because his family is Mexican
and all the actors were Mexican
or Mexican American --
and it's in Spanish,
so it's subtitled.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations.
That's a big deal.
-I'm, of course, the bad guy.
I'm the white military
industrial complex,
so I had a fabulous time.
-Wow.
-Because there's nothing better
than being bad.
-Yeah. I love that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Well, since you've been coming
here, I mean, I would say
probably "Late Night,"
you've been a friend of our show
and I appreciate it.
Every time you're on, it's fun.
You brought your dogs here
before.
-Yeah, my little creatures
all passed away.
[ Audience aws ]
Yeah, I can't talk about it
because I still get upset.
It was about a year ago.
And I was feeling sad,
and one of my sons said --
I said, "I can't get another
dog. I just can't."
You know, and he said,
"Well, then get cats."
And I'm bi, so...
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, wait, wait.
So you're -- you're --
You mean you like dogs and cats.
-I'm fluid.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You like dogs -- Yeah.
-I'm very fluid
where animals are concerned.
I've had cats before.
-You have?
-Then I had dogs.
Now I have cats.
[ Cheers ]
So, he found this advertisement.
You know, I was rescuing them.
-Yeah.
-And he found this cat.
And when I saw the picture of
this cat, it just made me laugh.
And I think you have
a picture of this cat.
-I do. This is Ida.
-This is Ida.
Have you ever seen
a sadder-looking cat?
[ Audience aws, laughs ]
Doesn't she look like the saints
they used to pray to?
[ Laughter ]
-Look at the frown.
-They said, you know,
she's very serious,
which I should have realized was
a red flag, but I didn't.
-A serious cat. They're all
kind of serious, right?
-A serious cat meaning
not social.
-Yeah. Yeah, of course.
-So, when I got her,
she was very feral. She's five.
And it took me a long time
to get her.
And I thought, you know,
she needs a friend.
That's what she needs
is a little friend.
-Okay.
-So, then I got another cat,
who is the sweetest -- I want to
preface this by saying
I have a tiny, tiny apartment.
Like, really tiny apartment.
I moved out of my family one.
So small I don't even
have doors, right?
So, I have this other little cat
that was kind of sick.
And so, very fragile and just as
sweet as can be.
And so we called her Sweetie.
-Okay.
-Do you have a picture of
Sweetie?
-I have a picture of Sweetie,
but I have a picture of Sweetie
looking very sweet
but I feel like -- is this Ida?
-Well, you have to separate
them.
-Alright, so let me just show
you this.
-There's --
[ Laughter ]
Ida did not want a friend.
-Here's Ida staring down like,
"Here's Johnny!"
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
[ Applause ]
-He's going to murder Sweetie.
-Yeah.
And I was really frightened
because Sweetie was really
fragile because she'd had
this operation when I got her.
She -- Anyway, it's tragic.
-Yeah.
-So, then I thought,
"Okay, this went on for a year."
At every opportunity she got,
she would beat her up.
So, I had to be very careful
with him, alright?
So what do you do?
I didn't want to give away Ida,
who was the bitch in the group.
But I didn't --
[ Laughter ]
So, what do you do?
You get another cat, right?
[ Laughter and applause ]
So I got a male cat this time.
I thought, "This is going to
change the dynamic."
And I got Harry,
who was only nine months old.
So I thought maybe
he's a little more malleable.
-You have to --
-Because he was younger
and he hasn't been on the street
as long.
And Harry is just
the sweetest guy ever.
But, of course, what happened
was that he plays with Ida
because he jumps all around
because he's a young cat and --
and Sweetie is like, "No, get
away. I don't want to touch --"
And he lies on his back
and he does all this stuff.
-You've become a cat lady.
You've become a cat lady.
-Yes. So, I don't know.
The question is now do I get a
dog to try to take care of...?
[ Laughter ]
-Please! No, no! It has to stop.
-Well, I don't know. If anyone
else out there has a plan...
-Yeah. No, no. This is good.
-I have catnip everywhere.
I've got these plug-in things
with pheromones.
It's just nothing is...
[ Laughter ]
-I want to ask --
-So that's my cat story.
-I want to ask you about this.
-And my son said --
-Yes?
-Who got the cats for me,
or the first one anyway, said,
"You know, it's very interesting
with men.
If you're a guy -- When you're
picking a guy, you know,
a man who likes a dog wants
immediate gratification
and someone who's
very dependent on them.
Because dogs understand that
they can't exist without you.
But cats, on the other hand,
they can deal with someone.
If a man has cats, then he knows
that you can be independent
and he's not as, you know, needy
as a dog lover
that needs that tail wagging as
soon as you come in the house."
[ Laughter ]
-Who said this to you?
-Don't you think that's true?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you obviously have dogs.
-Dogs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What are you, a psychic?
You're a psychic now.
-I rest my case.
-I want to ask you about this
because I think
it's very, very cool
and interesting,
and I want to know the story
behind it.
It seems like you always wear
this ja--
You bring this jacket out.
Every now and then,
you break it out, and it's
a very cool letterman leather --
it's like a "Simpsons" jacket,
and the Internet goes nuts
when you wear it because they
go, "What is this jacket?"
And even though the --
-No, they go nuts because
I'm still wearing that jacket
after many years.
And they're like, "What's wrong
with this person
that she's still wearing --"
-No, "vogue" had a headline,
"Has Susan Sarandon been wearing
the same jacket since 1995?"
[ Laughter ]
"Vogue" of all people.
-Faux pas.
-"Faux pas."
It's a fashion faux pas.
-Yeah, that's from
"The Simpsons."
And when you did -- I don't know
if they still do this,
but I did a few voices for them
and I --
"The Simpsons" are just
brilliant.
And they gave me this jacket.
And then, as they added
more characters,
they would put patches --
new patches -- on the jacket.
Now, I haven't -- I don't know
if they still --
but yes, that's --
Is there something wrong with
not throwing out your clothes?
I mean, maybe it's just because
I'm getting old,
but I want to hold on
to my old things.
-No, I love that you have this.
But it looks great on you.
-Thank you.
-Do you -- do you --
-I'll tell you what.
When I wear this jacket,
everybody smiles.
And so, I'm actually changing
the characteristics of New York
because people that see
this jacket go, "Cool jacket."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm spreading smiles.
-You really are spreading
smiles.
You're such a friend
of our show.
I wanted to give you --
-Get off my case.
-I wanted to give you
a little gift.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It says "Susan" on it.
-Let me see.
I think we --
What about patches though?
Do we get, like, the band?
-I can send you some patches.
-Can we get, like, all the faces
of the Roots?
-Yeah, the Roots. Oh, wait.
This is the new --
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is the new -- Yeah!
That's the new jacket.
Come on now.
That's what I'm talking about.
That is our gift to you.
-I feel super cool.
This is the best goody bag
so far of all the talk shows.
-You're already recognizable.
You're Susan Sarandon, but
a little "Susan" on there,
it kind of makes people smile.
-Then they don't confuse me
with Sigourney Weaver.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I'm talking about.
-And also, you know,
if I lose my mind,
I'll go, "Oh, right, I'm Susan."
-"I'm Susan." Yeah, of course.
Let's talk about "Monarch."
This is a big deal.
-Let's talk about "Monarch."
-It's got a lot of good buzz
here.
This Sunday, one of the most
anticipated new shows this fall.
Can you set up what
the show is about?
-Country music dynasty.
I am the head of the dynasty.
"I will do anything
for my family
to keep my dynasty going."
-Yes.
-And I have two daughters who,
you know, that could be trouble.
And a son. Trace Adkins.
-Trace Adkins.
-Who is a, you know, certified
major country star.
-Oh, my gosh.
He's, like, 8'9" by the way.
-And talks like --
and very Johnny Cash.
-[ Deep voice ] Very deep voice.
-And so it's, you know, a guilty
pleasure of lots of intrigue
and secrets and --
-[ Normal voice ] Who's taking
over the family biz
and country music and --
-And paternity and lies.
And yeah. Do I? Yeah.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-And who else?
-I love that.
-Shotguns going off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Susan Sarandon in
"Monarch." Take a look at this.
-It's time to show you what
you're wearing tomorrow
at the musical.
Ta-da!
-[ Gasps ] Oh!
It's perfect.
-You're perfect.
You know, Nicky, I never wanted
just to be a star.
I wanted to create a dynasty,
and I did.
We always knew that with your
God-given beauty and talent
that it was gonna be your
destiny to continue our legacy.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Susan Sarandon!
Check out the season premiere of
"Monarch"
this Sunday after NFL on Fox.